your work works on you more than you
work on it you build your character
through the work that we do we increase
our capacity to do work itself and so if
you can think about the work that you're
doing is increasing that trait rather
than the output of the work then i think
it will help a lot of people get through
some of the harder times it did for me
do the boring work and outwork yourself
doubt the biggest deficiency that people
have is their expectations because we
have these very lofty expectations
everyone's trying to become a
millionaire in 90 days when if i were to
get you to sign a contract this is i
promise you'll be a millionaire in five
years but you won't earn anything for
five years until you become a
millionaire would you be willing to sign
it most people say they would but they
don't live like they would and i promise
you that if you live like you would
you'll hit it what is my skill stack and
what are my deficiencies and which of
these deficiencies are keeping me from
what i want
and why am i not working on them
cool